[Musique]
bonjour sur le pêcheur sa mort avait
coiffé sjtu aux coûts qui ne cessent pas
faire comme un instant des chasseurs bat
la campagne
[Musique]
deux adorables petits credo qui joue ma
parole
il faut du tir au pigeon avec devrait
créer de pigeons
[Musique]
à paris loin des parieurs misent de
l'argent sur un combat de credo cote
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah ah
au même moment dans une arène rempli à
craquer des toreros font leur entrée
[Musique]
bientôt suivi par un credo toro et son
copain le credo moustiques
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais le credo toro joue avec son ami
on ne se rend pas compte du danger
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
what what ou arrachent aux asticots
arrache les crêpes aux pigeons
aller chasser asos tic
c'est péché avec des crédos pigeon petit
matou emporte les crédos cote
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pendant ce temps le credo thon rouge
joue toujours avec son petit copain le
credo rustique qui lui prend
tranquillement enfin tranquillement un
verre sur le nez du credo taureau
et les cris d'un coq fonce dans l'arène
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien fou
et voilà tout est rentré dans l'ordre le
petit asticot prend une douche les
crédos pigeon eau coule dans un
pigeonnier et les crédos coque courtisé
credo pour le credo toros traque avec
son copain de moustiques
or voilà tout est
[Musique]